Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday; I am hoooome!
Home is a nice place to be.
I missed you, slightly off-white bookshelf.
And you, Dutch nerdfighter shoes.
And I even missed you, probably mouse poop.
So Hank I really liked your video about the
Renaissance and circumstance and as I've been
re-reading Behind the Beautiful Forevers for
the nerdfighter book club--by the way, nerdfighters,
don't forget to read this book by June 10th!--anyway,
I've been thinking a lot about luck and deserving
what happens to you, probably in part because
I feel especially undeserving (with good reason)
of all the nice things that are happening
to me right now.
Like Hank, people keep congratulating me after
they see The Fault in Our Stars movie as if
I did anything, but all I did was get lucky.
Lucky that the book was published so well,
lucky to have a great cover, lucky that the
people I sold the movie rights to happened
to be brilliant, lucky that the wonderful
cast and crew and director came together to
make a great movie.
I mean Hank I didn't make savvy decisions
in this process or anything; I just got lucky.
There are much, much better books that have
been made into terrible, terrible movies.
But Hank of course the luck goes further back
than that because I'm lucky to have you as
a brother and collaborator.
I'm lucky that in 2007 you wrote a great song
about Harry Potter that gave us a whole new
audience.
I happened to be born into a rich country
and I happened to be born male and white in
a culture that privileges male-ness and white-ness.
And I write in English, Hank, which is a massive
advantage, I mean YA writers writing in Latvian,
even those far more talented than I am, rarely
find broad audiences.
Like Hank, all this Fault in Our Stars movie
stuff is not happening because I am a good
person; that's not the way the world works.
And I hope I can remember that because when
you start to think that the good things that
have happened to you have happened because
you worked harder than other people, or because
the universe prefers you, you start to see
the world with this weird, self-centered myopia,
and you don't commit yourself to lessening
inequality or to supporting marginalized voices
because you don't think there's a problem.
You start to think that the world is as it
should be.
Now obviously, this is very bad for other
people, but I think ultimately it's also bad
for you.
I don't mean you in particular, Hank, you're
a very nice person, I mean like the hypothetical
you.
Because there will come a day when awful and
unjust things happen to you, and if you believe
that you deserved the good things because
you were oh-so-good, does that mean you now
deserve the bad things?
I would argue that in addition to not deserving
all of the wonderful things that happen in
life, we don't deserve all of the terrible
things.
Like Hank, you don't deserve to have ulcerative
colitis; that's not fair.
No one deserves chronic pain or dementia or
poverty.
It's almost like "deserving" isn't the best
way to imagine it.
So Hank I keep meaning to mention this, but
over at Crash Course, we're about to teach
a ten-episode series in Big History.
This is possible because of a grant from one
of Bill Gates' organizations.
Basically we get to chart the history of the
universe, from the Big Bang to, like, now.
And I bring this up because in Big History,
we learn that 99.9% of matter in the Solar
System was sucked up by the Sun as it formed.
Everything else: Jupiter, the Atlantic Ocean,
my astonishingly diverse collection of Polo
shirts, the probable mouse poop, all of that
is the .1%.
In that context, everything in the solar system
not burning inside the Sun is on the very
far edge of the "good fortune" bell curve.
To me at least, Hank, it's not about deserving
anything, because you are not your luck.
No matter your circumstances, you are valuable
and rare and worthy of love.
And the great thing about humans, my favorite
thing about humans, actually, is that we can
work together to improve each other's chances
of having healthy and productive lives.
And whether it's cancer research or the Project
for Awesome or being kind to a stranger at
Walmart, for me, that is the only real path
to gratitude.
And I know that I'm saying this from an extremely
privileged position, but I really believe
that gratitude IS the proper response for
the absolute astonishment of getting to be
alive, and aware, and an essential part of
this crazy, sprawling story.
In short, Hank, I am very grateful to you
and to all of nerdfighteria.
Hey, I wanna tell you about two books I really
like.
I know that you're busy reading Behind the
Beautiful Forevers, but!
Everything Leads to You by Nina LaCour and
The Great Greene Heist by Varian Johnson,
both excellent!
Now I'm gonna try to go track down that mouse.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.